there was all this talk on social media
about you and and we know you heard it
and saw some of it
what type of response was this uh i mean
whatever it was i mean the bubble got
the best of me um i was just in a dark
place
i really wasn't here i checked out um so
these past couple games it was just
it was just difficult um but
you know shout out to people that stood
behind me
that was in my corner the positivity my
teammates
my family friends
everybody thank everybody that reached
out to me
i was just in a bad place and i found my
way i'm back and um
i look forward to the rest of this run
there seems to be a different
spirit about your team from the activity
on the bench to the way you defended
luca tonight
what was it that clicked for you and
your team tonight
uh for me it was you know it was just
hard to to
get into that that playoff mode
with no intensity here no fans no no
atmosphere i just
i just i was lost um i thought we
created the energy
i came in with that mindset that this is
staples
we at home uh the place is packed uh
i mean i really had to psych myself out
to get up
but you know i thought the whole team
took that
and we ran with it we created our own
energy like i said
and uh we decided dictated this game